you will read 25 to 50 faster  use a visual pacer as you underline the  words not skipping anything  test yourself i'm going to try this yeah  now here's why  first of all children do it until we  tell them not to do it if i ask you to  count the  number of lines you just read 100 of the  people use their finger and just  one two three because they know having a  visual pacer helps them focus  your eyes are attracted to motion if  you're in a bush hunting this rabbit and  all of a sudden the bush next to you  moves you have to look at what moves it  could be lunch you could be lunch  so you have to look at what's in your  peripheral field so if your finger is  going through the page like this your  attention is being pulled through  the information as opposed to your  attention being pulled apart